you looking like a vision tonight the
two of you very much Kaylee I want to
know from you miss Dr Fate over here was
rocking his wedding ring in this film
did you know that I didn't oh I didn't I
just found out about a week ago
I told her I did I I told her this this
is a wedding ring so and this is a watch
that Keely bought me many years ago with
an inscription that
time flies on loves loves Wings isn't
that beautiful so there you go so I
decided to wear it for this character it
see it seemed appropriate the man has
traversed the ages of time is one of the
most powerful Sorcerers in the DC Comic
Book World he did have a wife called
enza and she was even more powerful than
him I hear but anyway there you go it's
it's that touching for you to hear that
he wore this it is I love those emblems
that he took those with him into the
superpower superhero realm I'm just so
happy to be here in Times Square and
celebrating this magnificent movie which
is a feast of a film a beast of a film
yeah and for everyone involved Dwayne
has rocked it and brought it to this
night for everyone here I don't think
they'll be disappointed yeah Beautiful
cast Alderson you know Aldous harji
plays Hoffman he's just so magnificent
and Noah recently said in an interview
that you told him there are all
rehearsals before shooting a scene is
that the is that the method to your
brilliant sir you know sometimes you
move fast so you always have to be
prepared no one's going to direct you
you better be prepared so you read the
script you say yes to the script you're
going in and uh if they direction if
they can direct you then that's
wonderful but you know because sometimes
it's a very complicated
little scenario so uh and ultimately yes
got a few little bit of rehearsal then
you shoot it or you can rehearse it yeah
but ultimately you're shooting a
rehearsal
foreign